michael cohen spent a decade as trump's
high-profile
lobbyer toady defender and personal
attorney
and then one day he decided that he
hated donald trump and became donald
trump's mortal enemy
a big change how did that happen well
cohen told congress this week that he
had a kind of road to damascus
experience
he was personally and morally offended
by what his boss said
in two occasions first after the unite
the right rally in charlottesville that
was the summer of 2017
and later when he watched trump's
meeting with vladimir putin in helsinki
finland about a year later
those two scandals both of them
fraudulent entirely manufactured by the
left and its servants in the media
changed michael cohen's mind forever
democrats must be gratified to hear that
michael cohen is a sensitive progressive
now he is tormented by climate change
and his own toxic masculinity he's
basically a one-man crusade against
privilege he's a new man
that's his story well now comes a daily
mail piece that
puts a different gloss on it turns out
just weeks before the fbi raided his
offices last summer
michael cohen was shopping a book
proposal in the manuscript which the
daily mail has
cohen professes love and admiration for
donald trump
in the book proposal cohen defends the
president against claims that he is
quote
crazy dumb paranoid in over his head or
a liar
all claims that cohen made this week
before congress keep in mind that cohen
wrote the book proposal
well after charlottesville and helsinki
those scandals that just changed him as
a man
turns out that michael cohen is not a
very reliable narrator but
too late he's the narrator the democrats
have chosen and they're stuck with him
they brought him to capitol hill
yesterday in the hope the expectation
that he would prove the russia
conspiracy true
he didn't instead he demolished that
conspiracy nobody on the left wants to
admit that
but we have the tape let's start with
the claim that cohen held secret
meetings with russian agents in prague
in an effort to steal the 2016
election on its face it sounds nuts but
they've been telling you that
for years mcclatchy is reporting right
now that special counsel robert mueller
has evidence
that trump's personal lawyer and fixer
michael cohen secretly made a late
summer trip to prague during the 2016
presidential campaign according to two
sources familiar with the matter
confirmation of the trip would
confirm are from part of the steele
dossier when i hear now that their
reports that uh
mr cohen was in prague despite his
denials repeated denials uh
there is more and more uh indications
that uh
there is something here that is
far far from being anything near a witch
hunt
so that was john brennan whatever his
faults he was literally the head of the
cia the most powerful intelligence
agency in the world and as you just saw
he claimed to believe that oswald went
to mexico city cohen went to prague
it's the perfect conspiracy except that
michael cohen has never been to prague
he testified to that yesterday and by
the way he'd have no incentive to lie
about it
you have been to prague i've never been
to prague never have i've never been to
the czech republic
yeah my balance my time never been to
prague but i kind of like the music
how frustrating it must have been for
adam schiff to hear that never been to
prague
this was the part where michael cohen
was supposed to admit swapping microfilm
with vladimir putin in the sauna at the
prague marriott
instead he looked kind of mystified and
admitted he'd never even been to the
country
michael cohen is from long island he
pretty much stays there
okay let's try this again how about the
claim that vladimir putin's agents have
video of donald trump cavorting with
hookers
and that's how they've managed to
blackmail trump into saying nice things
about russia
we've been hearing about that since the
day buzzfeed first claimed it
the most incendiary claim in the steele
dossier
was of course that a foreign adversary
russia has dirt
on the president united states exposing
the president to blackmail
is the possibility the very real
possibility
that president putin holds damaging
information
over president trump what do the
russians have
on donald trump politically personally
or financially
yeah okay if there's a hooker tape out
there i think it's fair to assume that
michael cohen would know about it
he's that kind of guy a hooker tape kind
of guy
now would probably be the time he'd tell
us all about it but no
are you aware of anything that the
president uh has done
at home or abroad that may have
subjected him to or may subject him to
extortion or blackmail
i am not no okay um are you
aware of any videotapes that may be
the subject of extortion or blackmail
i've heard about these tapes for a long
time
i've had many people contact me over the
years
i have no reason to believe that that
tape exists
oh damn he did it again strang from the
script
instead of confirming the russia
conspiracy that has dominated and
controlled american politics
for more than two years michael cohen
just refuted it what kind of witness is
this guy
anyway this is getting very frustrating
where do we get to the part where he
blows the russia case
wide open and they lead big orange away
in handcuffs and hillary can be the
president
well here's an idea let's just ask him
directly did the trump campaign collude
with the russian government during the
2016 election
michael cohen would know he was there by
the way it's almost a rhetorical
question
democrats have long been absolutely
certain that it happened
i think there's plenty of evidence of
collusion or conspiracy in plain sight
trump has the kremlin
clan surrounding him
there's more to be learned about it i
believe there's been collusion
it's starting to smell more and more
like collusion
we saw cold hard evidence
of the trump campaign indeed the trump
family
eagerly intending to collude possibly
with russia these people
plenty of evidence cold hard evidence
well if anyone could provide
that kind of evidence it would be
michael cohen after all he was donald
trump is that really his name
no it's danelle trepanovich he was
danelle trepanovich's personal attorney
during the years that trapanovich was
accepting suitcases full of rubles in
exchange for subverting american
democracy
so what's the answer mr cohen
based on what you know would mr trump
or did he lie about colluding
and coordinating with the russians at
any point during
the campaign so as i stated in my
testimony
i wouldn't use the word colluding
was there something odd
about the back and forth praise
with president putin yes
but i'm not really sure that i can
answer that question
in terms of collusion
well the balloon just deflated talk
about a letdown
no meeting in prague no blackmail no
collusion
no russia conspiracy at all it was all
a hoax it was a much less interesting
loch ness monster
you've got to be feeling a little silly
right now if you ever believed any of
this but wait
okay we got one last idea there is still
a way
michael cohen could send donald trump to
prison
even without russia what if cohen could
confirm
that trump once told him to lie to
congress that would be obstruction of
justice at the very least it would
certainly be a crime
buzzfeed ran a story alleging that
happened
yes buzzfeed is a cat blog run by
unhappy people in brooklyn
but who knows maybe there's something
there certainly cable news was convinced
this would be certainly a bombshell
information buzzfeed's latest bombshell
report the white house is slamming a
bombshell report by buzzfeed
with a bombshell report from buzzfeed if
the buzzfeed bombshell is true
bombshell report the latest bombshell
from the cat blog
our last hope to end this infernal
presidency and return to the happy
status quo of 2010
our hopes are on you michael cohen did
it actually happen the reveal please
you lied to those congressional
committees is that correct
previously correct yes sir you stated
that trump never directed you to lie to
congress is that correct
that's correct no
four for four michael cohen strikes out
game set match the trump presidency
continues
the other team looks despondent you can
hear weeping from the press box
but wait before we head to the parking
lot and drive home
one final piece of business what about
all the lies you just heard not from
cohen from the others
blackmail collusion russia russia russia
are any of the liars who told those lies
going to be punished for lying
is anyone going to lose a job or a
reputation
or a contributor contract maybe just
what happened to carter page that might
be enough
is there any penalty for being
relentlessly and recklessly dishonest
for two solid years for intentionally
misleading the public in the service of
a political agenda and a political party
the democratic party is a single person
even going to concede
what just happened much less apologize
for it
of course not it's washington i'll be
promoted tomorrow you watch